The most heroic thing we can do now look the truth in the face
the night king is coming
the dead are already here the night king
made them all they follow his command if
he falls getting to him may be our best
chance if that's true
he'll never expose himself yes he will
he'll come for me. hi everyone its
Charlie this is going to be my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 3 trailer video
obviously the big Battle of Winterfell
so we got to talk about the footage
that's going on here the plan that they
made who we think is going to survive who
we think is going to go out and what the big twists are going to be because I don't
think any of us expect the battle to go
down the way they think it will based on
the planning session that they had and
what brand told them remember what
Tyrion said during the episode sometimes
clever people the most clever people
overestimate their cleverness
and bran thinks he's pretty clever right
now so if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Game of
Thrones videos there's a new round of
that HBO now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so we'll start with
the footage first and what the people
are saying during the trailer the
obvious stuff then we'll talk about what
we think is misleading what's missing
from the trailer then we'll talk about
death predictions so we start with the
voiceover from a sanso saying the most
heroic thing we can do now is look the
truth in the face she's probably
referring to the fact they're just
looking their own deaths in the face
like we all might go out tonight
because most of the characters are fair
game to go there are only a couple of
people that I think are safe with plot
armor and have to survive to the last
couple of episodes but based on what
torment told them when he arrived with
the brothers of the Nights Watch
the White Walkers are arriving just
before dawn it makes it sound like the
battle will end by dawn meeting most of
this will take place in the dark
and it looks like the White Walkers
create a winter storm to cloud their
vision to make it much harder for them
to coordinate their armies make all the
jokes you want about cranking the
brightness up on your screens so much of
my time after I finished making Game of
Thrones videos it's just going back into
the Edit and cranking the brightness way
up so that everybody could just pick out
what's going on in each of the frames
because of the way they light stuff they
give you a bunch of different views of
their combined armies
informations starting with the unsullied
legions the trebuchet is the smaller
catapults the siege weapons in front but
you have the Dothraki bloodrider
standing in front of them then you have
Jon Snow up on a hill face looking down
on their forces at Winterfell from a
nearby clip
they're both dragon riders now because
Jon has learned to ride Rago
so maybe this is them just taking the
dragons for a loop around the area to
get a better look at things before the
start of the battle Samwell watching the
unsullied march by we haven't seen a lot
of Samwell footage from the other
trailers in this big battle scene so I'm
assuming that he's just going to help the
others inside the castle when the whites
eventually make it over the wall Samwell
Tarly Slayer of White Walkers lover of
ladies Orion Sansa up on the walls Davos
elsewhere also on the walls walking past
the northern soldiers down in the crypts
it's Varys Gilly little Sam the little
girl that gave DuBose the Shireen
Baratheon flashback it's a little too
blurry and dark in here to see which
stark tomb they're sitting next to but
we'll probably get a better look for it
during the episode but they're probably
on the upper levels of the crypts the
underground structure has way more
levels goes way deeper in his way larger
than the actual above ground Winterfell
Castle I did a whole history video on
the crypts of Winterfell a little while
ago but they go back to the time of bran
the Builder the lower you go the older
of the tombs are I know there are a lot
of people asking what's going on with
this plan to put them in the crypts
because it's all dead people they're
sitting around dead people
the Nike and the White Walkers raised
things as whites well here's the thing
about that I think there are a couple of
practical reasons why the people in the
crypts are mostly safe not completely
safe but mostly safe the doors to the
crypts are made of really thick iron
wood which is impervious to most kinds
of fire and it's almost as strong as
steel but also number two I think the
Gilly and little Sam are safe so I think
that most of the people around here
would be safe because if you turned one
or two of these people then the rest
would be dead because they really are
fish in a barrel so they'll probably be
some moment where the whites almost bang
down the door before they're able to
stop them above ground they'll probably
take it right to the edge like the
whites almost get into the crypts but
they don't quite make it in so I'm not
expecting any really big danger for the
people down here there's a sort of
tyrion elsewhere
side on the walls sir Jorah upon the
line in the thick of it on horseback
with hearts pain thank you very much
Samwell be sure to give that back when
you're done with it unless you die then
Samwell have to go find it himself
John says the night king is coming but
there's a shot of him on the ground with
smoke all around him because of that
winter storm that they create so it's
really hard to tell where he is during
this shot but it looks like he's seeing
something he can barely believe the
expression on his face is one of shock
and surprise there's a much wider shot
of their armies outside the gates of
Winterfell this is actually lit pretty
well there's the Dothraki bloodrider ZUP
in the front the siege weapons behind
them the unsullied legions these people
over on the bottom right here with the
taller looking shields and some of the
dragonglass pikes seem like they're the
northern soldiers I'm assuming the
Knights of the Vale are standing off to
one side here just off of frame there's
a same shot of Arya running through the
upper levels of the castle probably from
some White's chasing her who have made
it over the walls she doesn't have her
special weapon the Gendry made for her
so she may have lost it at this point
maybe she still has that Valyrian dagger
on her hip there's another shot of the
unsullied legions outside the castle as
the winter winds blow all around them
this probably just means the army of the
Dead is much closer to them in the winds
that they're creating or just making it
much harder and harder for them to see
getting thicker and thicker that's
actually a really creative use of their
powers create a giant winter wind to
obfuscate their vision so it's much
harder coordinated and it makes it way
harder for the dragons in the air like
Daenerys and John Snow to see what
they're doing
there's the Hound with his new dragon
glass ax & barrack with his usual
flaming sword inside the castle looking
like they're trying to hunt something
down there look they're trying to be
really careful so something is clearly
going on inside Winterfell during the
battle there's a shot of what seems like
Daenerys on dragons back amidst this
giant winter storm just trying to
survive through it I saw a lot of
questions about what's going on with
this dragon in my feed but if you look
on its back there's a little tiny figure
with long white hair blowing all around
in the wind and they're hugging the
dragon back as close as possible like
they're trying to hunched over to avoid
this winter storm so that's why I think
that this dragon is drogon in is
Daenerys on his back I don't think that
it's the night king of Viserion because
Viserion is a much deeper shade of blue
with piercing blue eyes in the teeth
coming out of his mouth look way more
menacing than dragon's teeth they just
designed him to look like a much more
or some dragon now that he's a white
then drogon even though drogon is much
bigger in size the unsullied legions
enter their battle posture then there's
Theon in the godswood with a flaming
dragon glass arrow getting ready to
protect brand with the other Ironborn
Jon Snow pulling out long claw near a
tree this might be the godswood - but
it's really hard to tell I'm guessing
that wherever he goes during the battle
he won't stray too far from Winterfell
then Daenerys turns to Jon Snow and says
the dead are already here still pretty
clearly pissed about what happened at
the end of episode two the Rhaegar fell
on the chart a son but they leave the
trailer off with Brienne shouting - pod
and the Knights of the Vale - stand
their ground as it seems like the
legions of whites have already started
making their run on Winterfell like here
they come right now I know a lot of you
are hoping for I spiders big as hounds
because we barely got a wide shot of the
White Walkers marching their horses into
frame so we haven't got a full shot of
the army of the Dead yet so you don't
know what else they're going to surprise us
with but outside of the Giants that the
White Walkers have turned and maybe a
few other large animals I'm not going to
hold my breath for giant ice spiders
even though that would be really really
cool
there were a lot of people that were
confused about this shot of the White
Walkers marching into frame - because a
lot of people saw the curved ice blade
in the middle here that the knight King
uses and they thought that this person
might be him but you notice that the
knight king does not have a beard the
person with the curved blade here has a
beard so that is not the night King it's
just another one of Gilley's presumable
cousins that's right they're all
fighting Gilley's family that's who all
these White Walkers are as far as we
know what is the big twist of the
episode though is that we don't see the
night king anywhere in this trailer but
they're all convinced that he's coming
bran made this huge plan to try and trap
him or lure him out into the gods were
using himself as bait I think it's
important to remember what Tyrion said
to Jamie during the episode about all
his failures in battle planning I made a
mistake common to clever people I
underestimated my opponent so think
about it this way maybe the night King
has been using brands abilities against
him because brands said that the night
King has been trying to get all the
three-eyed Ravens going back thousands
of years unsuccessfully so the Nike is
not dumb although
three-eyed Ravens had the advantage of
unbroken magical seals protecting them
when he broke the seal by grabbing brand
and marking him that's really what
tipped it off and we know that bran is
still kind of learning his abilities
he's much better than he was last season
but he still doesn't know everything so
in the way that clever people
underestimate their opponents I think
that bran is under estimating the night
king John snow made it sound like it
would be the easiest thing in the world
we just get the night king and we take
care all of this stuff clearly that is
not going to be the case the battle will
not go down the way they think so let me
know in the comments what do you think
that the night king is going to do to
swerve on their plan to trap him during
the episode he could either not show up
at all or he could only show up for a
couple minutes in the episode and then
completely take off leaving them
confused wait a minute where the night
king go well we still have all these
White Walkers and whites to defeat as
far as death predictions go though this
is a solid episode for them to shed a
lot of their secondary characters and
maybe a few main characters too and
don't forget a few characters might come
back as whites
during the battle they're only couple
though I'm not expecting every single
dead person to come back as a white but
I think it's actually better to say
which characters we think are totally
safe so these are the characters that I
think are wearing plot armor and have to
survive to at least the last couple of
episodes yep Jon Snow Daenerys and at
least one of the Dragons probably drogon
is safe Arya Stark Samwell Gilly little
Sam Tyrion in the Little Bear like we
saw ghost during last week's episode I
think it's possible that they could get
ghost during this episode Nymeria is
still alive so if she and her super pac
show up 50-50 on whether or not she
survives the battle pretty much anyone
in the north that's not on my plot armor
list is fair game to go including
Melisandre because I think that they're
going to almost lose the battle really
really badly but I'm expecting some sort
of Melisandre Knights of the Vale moment
during the third act with the red
priests or whoever it is that she went
over to get support from it's just
assuming that it would be other red
priests and maybe the fiery hand
she even prophesied her own death when
she was talking to Varys before she went
back to volantis so don't worry I'll be
back because we have to die in this
strange land let me know in the comments
though do you guys actually think that
Melisandre will show up during the
battle at some point what will happen to
is I will do a Q&A video but that'll
probably post on Wednesday because I'm
allowed to post my non-spoilery Avengers
end game review Tuesday afternoon
so look out for that we have both
Avengers in game this week and the
biggest battle in Game of Thrones
history so be sure to stay alive all
week so that you get to see it all it is
going to be an amazing week but
congratulations to the last giveaway
winner and ER Zuza please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details while you wait for
everything click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 2 video and
click here for my episode 1 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!